next I like to introduce our civil
matter metal winner for his film will
please welcome director on song Lee
thank you very much well first of all I
like to thanks to academy and I know
that I made a lot of trouble even
beginning of the process where I lost my
HD came and I was always late to the
event and I'm thanks to rich Miller for
understanding everything yeah and um
thanks first of all I'd like to thank my
parents who supported me mentally in
everything to uh let me make this film
and when he was since he was like
talking about a lot of heavy topic I was
a having kind of a lot of sad days and
my parents and my friends always
encouraged me so I like things more than
anything and Julian clears who wrote
amazing amazing music for my film thank
you very much we could have made it here
but Dario with the voice from my film we
spent a lot of hours of sad and very
intimate recording time in my car thank
you very much Dario and more than
anything this event has been amazingly
inspiring I'm as a young filmmaker
actually made finish this film a year
ago and I've been out of the school and
this event reminding me once more that I
want to keep making film and remind me
of my own passion wants more of our
animation film making so thank you very
much